FEMALE SPEAKER: So
today, Earth Day,
2016, we're very lucky
to have Louie Psihoyos,
the director of the Academy
Award winning film "The Cove"
to talk about his latest
film "Racing Extinction."
It's an honor to
have you here, Louie.
How are you?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: Glad to be here.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How
are you doing today?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: Good.
Good.
I just from Tribeca
Film Festival
just a few minutes ago.
I got something called
a Disruptor Award, which
back when I was a kid,
you'd call it an award
for being a troublemaker.
But it was as exciting.
There was a few
thousand people there.
And the people there were
there to celebrate people
that are trying to change
the world with film,
and you know, the guy
from the Charity Water--
a lot of different
organizations.
I just built like-- all we did
was a little bit of building.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That's pretty good.
You're actually from New
York originally, right?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: I lived here.
I am from Chelsea originally.
I used to live up at 23rd
between 10th and 11th Avenue
back when this was a
really bad neighborhood.
The selling point when I got
my place was from the landlord.
He said, from this window,
you can see a crime an hour.
I thought that was really cool.
That was back when I
was your age in my 20s.
And I thought that was
pretty exciting then.
I was working at "National
Geographic" at that point.
And then I started an
organization called the Oceanic
Preservation Society.
And I moved recently a little
bit closer to the ocean.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So you're
not in Denver anymore?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: I
used to be in Boulder.
I was in Boulder
for about 25 years.
I was running the
Oceanic Preservation
Society from Boulder.
And we used to say we're
a conveniently located
between two oceans.
But now within the
last six months,
I moved out to Northern
California based out of there.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
what brought you
from doing photography
for "National
Geographic" to filmmaking?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: A
friend of mine--
this will be probably be
interesting to the tech people
here.
But a good friend of mine
that was my dive buddy
was Jim Clark, the guy
that started Netscape,
Silicon Graphics, WebMD.
Netscape was the first
commercial internet browser.
I photographed him for
"Fortune Magazine."
I used to be a photographer
in a former life.
And I photographed
him when he built
this big boat called Hyperion
that had the world's tallest
mast.
And we were hanging
out in Amsterdam.
His boat was being launched.
And we found out we
both liked to dive.
And he said, Louie,
would you teach me
how to be a good photographer?
And I said, Jim, I'll teach
you how to be a great one
if you teach me how
to be a billionaire.
And so he would pick
me up on his plane.
And we would go around
the world and go
to some of the
most amazing places
in the world-- places I could
never have done on my own.
And I taught him photography.
We just explored.
And this was the third time
we were in the Galapagos.
And there was fisherman
illegally long
lining in a marine
sanctuary all around us and.
And Jim said, somebody should
do something about this.
And I said, how about you and I?
And he said, what do you mean?
I said, we'll use your
money, and my eye,
and we'll make films.
And I thought that
was-- to me, I always
wanted to be a filmmaker.
I'd worked for
"National Geographic"
as a still photographer.
But it wasn't my
area of expertise.
And so he was going to fund
me for about a million dollars
a year, which is a
hefty amount of money.
It was a good amount of money
for a documentary filmmaker.
But I've never made a
film before in my life.
And so now, we were on vacation
together down in the Caribbean.
And my kid is
playing on the beach
with another kid whose father
is a pretty well-known film
director.
And Steven Spielberg
comes over to the boat
and says, I said to
him, Mr. Spielberg,
do you have any advice for
a first-time filmmaker?
He said, yeah never make a movie
involving any boats or animals.
Now, the first film
I did was "The Cove,"
which became the most winning
documentary in history.
It won over 70 top film
awards from Sundance
to the Academy Award.
But that was our first film.
But the idea was-- did
people here see "The Cove"?
A couple?
Yeah, so about half the people.
Another half
probably heard of it,
or they're scared to
see it, because it
has the stigma of being
a really violent film.
And it has one
section in it that is
pretty-- it is hard to watch.
It was hard for me to make.
We had planted hidden
cameras in this place
where they killed more dolphins
than any place in the world.
This is where they supply--
this place in Taiji, Japan--
they kill several
thousand dolphins a year.
And the ones that are
looking for young females
that they put into service in
the captive dolphin industry.
Most of them swim with dolphin
parks in Asia and Europe
and come out of this
one little cove.
And we saw how do they
kill these animals?
What do they do with them?
We planted these hidden cameras.
And it' sort of became
like a James Bond movie.
The whole film
took a turn when we
decide to sneak into this cove.
And it became really exciting.
It wasn't just a
documentary anymore.
It was like-- I think
"Rolling Stone" called
the movie a cross between
the "Bourne Identity"
and "Flipper."
And it was exciting.
We had some amazing footage
that came out of there.
But here's the really
cool thing about the film
aside from all
the awards that we
got from doing that one film is
that they were killing 23,000
dolphins and porpoises
a year in Japan
when we started that movie.
Now, they are killing
less than 6,000
mostly because of that
movie, because in the movie,
we explain that
how they're killed.
And we also explain that
these animals are toxic.
A dolphin today,
because of the ocean
is so polluted by what we
put into it-- for those
who haven't seen the movie or
don't remember the movie if you
saw it-- there are
six levels of the food
chain in the ocean from
plankton up to dolphins.
And at every tropic level,
each of those trophic levels
is an order of magnitude
more pollution.
So a pound of swordfish or
a pound of dolphin flesh
has a million times
more pollutants in it
than a pound of
plankton, because it all
gets magnified up
the food chain,
to the point where
a dolphin washing up
on the coast of New
York state right now
has about 6,000 parts
of PCBs in them.
That would be eligible
for a Superfund site--
just that one dolphin.
And now people in
Japan are eating this.
So just by giving them the
information that the government
wasn't giving them, because you
go to the Minister of Health's
website in Japan, they
had advisories for women
to be eating dolphin meat,
even thought it's toxic.
One piece of toxic
dolphin meat could
be enough to maybe
make your fetus abort.
And so now those numbers
dropped precipitously.
And I'll just steamroll
right into the next idea.
So I'm at Sundance with
"The Cove" as our premier.
And my own background
is that when
I worked at National
Geographic, I
did stories on the Mesozoic--
the mid-life of the planet--
this is the age of dinosaurs--
and dug up dinosaurs
all around the world.
I did a book on dinosaurs
called "Hunting Dinosaurs."
And I used basically 50
of the top paleontologist
in the world as tour guides
through the Mesozoic.
So I know a bit
about this subject.
I spent 10 years
working in that world.
But at Sundance, I
brought a book with me--
it was called "Terra" by Michael
Novacek, the head provost
American Museum of Natural
History at 81st and Columbus.
And in the book, he's talking
about how we're losing species
now faster than
mankind's ability
to record these animals are
even on the planet with us.
And I thought, this is horrific.
And I didn't want--
that's not the headspace
I wanted to be in.
I wanted to show them
the premier of my film.
So I picked the only other
book I brought with me.
But this was by Charles Veron,
former chief marine scientist
for Australia.
In the book he is talking about
we're losing the Great Barrier
Reef now and all other
reefs on the planet because
of acidification.
That's exactly what goes on
before a mass extinction event.
That's what we're going
through right now.
And I thought here I am running
this organization called
the Oceanic
Preservation Society.
I consider myself a lay
expert in this field.
And I had no idea that we were
losing the oceans that quick.
I had no idea we were in the
middle of what scientists
are calling the
Anthropocene-- the age of man.
This is an epoch
where we are leaving
a mark on the fossil record
of the future to the point
that future generations can see
that there's a line we arrived.
They're probably
not going to be--
they'll be looking at the
computers in the garbage dump.
And they're going to see--
it will be like an iridium
layer-- you know,
when the comet hit
the dinosaurs 65
million years ago,
it wiped out all
the large dinosaurs.
It was left with
an iridium layer.
There's not dinosaurs
above that iridium layer.
But there's a
dinosaurs below it.
So we know that there
was a catastrophic event.
When future
generations look back
at our plume of
the iridium layer,
they're going to
see our garbage.
And I think that if we don't
do a great job at trying
to mitigate this
problem, we're not
going to looking to say how
great our computers are,
how great our technology
is, how wonderful it
is that we can communicate
at the speed of light
across the planet.
They're going to say that
this generation presided
over the biggest
apocalypse on the planet
since the dinosaurs were
wiped out by a comet
65 million years ago.
So it just shocked
me at Sundance
to realize that we were in
the middle of this epoch
that I was oblivious
to, because when
you're digging dinosaurs
around the planet,
you're looking around at these
graveyards like in the Gobi
Desert with Michael Novacek.
And you almost trip
over dinosaurs.
You think, what happened here?
What went on?
And it's sandstorms and
all this cataclysmic stuff.
In the iridium layer, it's
pretty easy to spot it.
But to think that
we're going to an event
like that right now, because
this is comfortable-- we're all
having lunch.
It's air conditioned air.
We can communicate
on our phones,
and at the speed of light,
thoughts that we might have.
But it to the natural world,
to the rest of the planet,
we're just one species.
We don't even know by
an order of magnitude
how many animals
we're sharing it with.
But we know we're
losing faster than we
can record that they're here.
Some people say 8.5
million, 10 million.
We've only identified about a
million and a half species out
of the whole catalog of
maybe 8 million, 30 million,
100 million species.
We don't even know.
So I look at things
because of hanging around
with paleontologist, I look at
things a little bit different.
They have an appreciation
of what's called deep time
where the guys go
and dig up dinosaurs.
But they're not looking
at-- they're not
thinking about-- they might
be thinking about lunch.
But they're also thinking
about the animals
that they are digging.
How do they fit into this
whole history of life?
And now, as a photographer
and as a filmmaker
I'm trying to
think of how do you
make a film about perhaps
the most cataclysmic event
in the world that
nobody knows about,
but give them a sense of
hope after they see the film.
There's something
that we can do.
I don't want to just make a
film like a NOVA film, which
are really well produced,
but don't give you
tangible ideas of what
you can do to change it,
because this is a planetary
disaster on the scale that
is unprecedented.
You can't be saying that
the house is burning down.
You have to say, what can you do
to get buckets of water on it?
So that was "Racing Extinction."
But the film-- when you do
it normal Hollywood film,
they look at you, the audiences,
$10 and a box of popcorn.
You're just butts in seats.
And I don't look at documentary
filmmaking like that.
I look at you as minds in
seats and more importantly,
minds and hearts in
seats, because the science
shows that people don't
change behavior on what
they learn-- what they think.
You have to change
their heart first.
You can talk about 30,000
species dying every day.
And it's just a calculation.
That's a number.
It's a statistic.
But early in the film,
"Racing Extinction,"
we show the scene--
and actually, you
might want to direct
this a little bit more.
You can stop me
anytime you want.
But at the beginning of this
film, I find a buoy on a beach.
It was down in the
Dominican Republic.
And this fisherman had brought--
said you guys are from America.
Can you give me $500 as
a reward for this buoy?
And I said, let me see
what this buoy looks like.
And it was a big
thing and not too
easy to carry back
up to America.
But it was actually owned by
a friend of mine, Chris Clark
from the Cornell
bioacoustical laboratory.
He runs the biggest repository
of animal sounds on the planet
And after I returned
this buoy, he
tells me, Louie, just about
everything on the planet's
been singing.
We just haven't been listening.
We're losing these voices.
He plays for me the
voice of an o'o.
This is a bird from Kauai--
the small island of Kauai
in the Hawaiian Islands.
And he tells me that
these birds mate for life.
And a dueting pair
where he'll sing.
Then she answers with a song.
And it's a beautiful duet.
But he's only playing me
the male side of the duet.
And there's a gap where
the female should be.
And he says, you know why?
He says, that's the
last male of the species
singing for a female
that will never come.
That breaks my heart.
And it should break
everybody's heart,
because you can identify.
It's no longer just one of the
30,000 species, some number.
It's like you can identify
with that one animal.
It's like the martian in
the film that came out.
There's a whole film based on
one guy's trying to survive.
But you can imagine where
there's no hope for this bird.
Michael Novacek was
saying to me that after I
came back and
interviewed him, he said,
he was doing a dissertation.
There was five grad students
doing their dissertations.
And three of them were
doing dissertations
on the birds of Hawaii.
I think five of the
birds went extinct
in the three-year
period that they
were working on the papers.
That's how fast things
are disappearing.
So to me, it's really crucial
to make a movie, to get it out
there at light speed
so people can start
getting their heart changed,
because the solutions,
which we can talk about later,
are really fairly simple.
There's five major
drivers of extinction
is habitat destruction,
pollution, invasive species,
over-consumption-- just
that four-- I can't
remember the fifth one.
We try to address
them all in the movie.
But the idea is that the
biggest problem with extinction
is habitat destruction.
And that's because we're
tearing down rain forests.
We're tearing down
natural habitat
to grow food for animals
that we're going to eat.
And you guys are engineers.
You are thought leaders.
Now, think about this.
If you had a pile of
grain on the table,
and you could either
eat that yourself
to get your protein
and your nutrition,
or you can give six times
that amount to an animal
that you're trying to eat
so you can get it's flesh,
it's a really bad
exchange of energy.
But that's what we're
doing all over the planet.
There's a really dangerous
myth that we need
meat for human consumption.
We think, oh, to be
a man to be strong
you have to eat that way.
You have to eat an animal.
Well, in fact, the next
movie I'm working on
is called "Game Change."
It's being executive produced
by James and Suzy Cameron
from "Avatar."
And one of the
heroes in our movie
is a guy that won the-- this
is a documentary by the way.
So he was an ultimate
fighting champion.
And he got injured.
And he thought, well, what
can I do for nutrition?
What's the best way?
What can I eat to heal myself.
And he found very little
information out there
and that most
doctors do 14 years
of learning to be a
doctor, but not have
a single hour in your
curriculum of nutrition.
But he found out that
the gladiators, which
were the first ultimate
fighting champions,
were actually vegans.
They didn't eat meat.
These two professors
from Austria,
who we just interviewed
last month, went in.
And they looked at
the strontium levels
in the teeth and the bones.
And they could determine
that, in fact, they
were not meat eaters.
They were vegetarians.
They were vegans.
In fact, they were
called the barleymen.
When they go back into
the documentation,
they found that was
one of the concoctions
that they ate for protein.
It's a very recent
myth that you have
to eat animals for
human consumption.
We've just been sold a bill
of goods about all this.
If you look at your teeth,
if you have cats or dogs,
go back and look
at their dentition.
They're carnivores.
But the back molars--
there's no back molars--
but they have very pointy,
sharp teeth with serrations
that are used for gulping meat.
And it goes into a very
short digestive track.
But we have incisors
here that are
used to crunch through an
avocado or a piece of fruit.
And these molars
are used to crush
beans, legumes, vegetables.
We are omnivores.
But our gut tract
and our teeth is
all about being a vegetarian.
Sort of fast
forwarding into that,
but we want to talk obviously
about extinction more.
So the idea is how do you
scale up these issues?
Look what we did with "The
Cove" with 23,000 dolphins down
to 6,000.
And I think, OK, mass
extinction event.
How do you get that film out
there and get people to see it.
So I knew it was about scale.
So we had the film at
Sundance this last year.
And we licensed it to
the Discovery Channel.
There's a reason we did it,
because they were paying us
a lot of money
for a documentary.
I was only-- still only
$0.30 on the dollar,
because you don't make a
lot of money when you do
documentaries.
But they promised us
a global audience.
And they put it out in 220
countries and territories
on a single day.
And 36 million people
saw it the first weekend.
It's showing, again, I think
either tonight or tomorrow,
"Racing Extinction"
But 36 million
is a really good launch
for f documentary.
But what you need to do
though is get it up to scale.
It doesn't matter if 36
million people see it.
What you need is
10% or up to 16.5%
of the population to
see it before-- that's
the tipping point-- what Malcolm
Gladwell talks in his book
about.
But the science shows you
might need is a little as 10%
of the people that have an
unwavering belief in the truth.
And then the rest of the
population falls like dominoes.
And in "Racing Extinction," we
had premiered at the Tribeca
Film Festival-- I think it
was like the year before last
with this film.
And it was a rough cut-- the
Tribeca Film Festival where
I just got back from 20 minutes
ago, is going on right now.
But we did a rough
cut screening.
And in that screening,
what we do is
we are trying to alert
the world that there's
a mass extinction going on.
And Ban Ki-moon, who's the
Secretary General of the United
Nations, allowed us the day
before the big climate march
in New York, allowed us to
use the building as these
for these projections to give
endangered species a voice.
We took the 39-story
Secretariat Building--
used that for a big canvas and
then used the General Assembly
Building.
It was five IMAX
screens together.
We tiled about 16, 30,000-lumen
projectors together to do this
huge projection event.
But I'd always wanted-- That
was the same right before we
got here that I usually stay
at the Maritime Hotel right
across the street.
And Eric Goode,
who runs the hotel,
saves endangered species,
loves the work we do,
and he always gives me
the penthouse suite,
which overlooks the
Empire State Building.
And I thought I want to light
up the Empire State Building
with endangered species.
And we had a scene in there that
was Tony Malcolm, who owns it,
is a good friend of mine.
And he said, well, Louie, if
you can get permission to do it,
I'll let you use the building.
And I've been trying
for four years
to light up the building
since the last two years
of the Bloomberg administration.
And I was at an event
right before the COP21.
And there was 50
heads of organizations
like the Sierra Club,
Greenpeace, myself,
in the room over at Norman
and Lyn Lear's house.
Norman Lear is the most
successful producer
ever for television.
And the first film I did, "The
Cove," was sold at their house.
We couldn't sell it at Sundance
six years ago when we came out.
But in that room were two
people-- the head of Lionsgate
and Jeff Skoll from--
what's the company?
What does he do?
PayPal?
Jeff Skoll.
Help me out.
You guys have to know who he is.
Anyway, he was
Participant Media.
Anyway, Lionsgate
bought the film.
Jeff Skoll that runs
Participant Media
does outreach campaigns
for films like ours.
He said, if you buy the film,
I'll do the outreach campaign.
And so in that room, it was
a very powerful room to be.
That made my life go around.
So five years later,
now I'm sitting
in this room with 50 of the
heads of these organizations
and five the people down
below Ban Ki-moon working
on the environment before COP21.
And Lyn says to
me, Louie, can you
talk about your movie,
"Racing Extinction," which
was over at that point.
We had the ending
with the UN in it.
And I said, well, I don't
want to talk about the movie
so much, but what
I've been trying
to do to really end the movie
is to light up the Empire State
Building.
Does anybody in this room
know Bill de Blasio--
the mayor of New York?
And Norman Lear, who is
leaning up against the wall,
says, I know Bill.
And he flies to New
York the next day.
It was on a Saturday
at this house.
And the next Wednesday,
I get an e-mail
from Bill de Blasio
saying, cool,
how do we make this happen?
And so right there, we
got the wheels in place
to light up the
Empire State Building.
Now, the problem
was our distributor
was like, you know what, Louie?
The movie is good
enough the way it is.
You don't need to touch it.
It's great.
It was a wonderful,
global ending to the film.
And he said, it's August.
You want to do this?
Everybody that's
important in New York,
in August, they're
going to be gone.
They are going to
be at the Hamptons.
be over in Europe.
And on a Saturday night, none
of the media's going to show up.
Nobody can afford to have
crews working overtime
on a Saturday night.
It will be a nonevent.
We did it anyway.
And we closed down
traffic on 5th Avenue.
Taxis were stopping
in the middle
of the street with their fares,
and getting out, and taking
their cellphone pictures.
There was tens of thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands
of people on the street and
on the rooftops shooting this.
And what we didn't count on,
we didn't even think about,
is the viral nature of everybody
with a cell phone putting it
on with their 1,000
friends on Instagram,
or Twitter, or Facebook.
We became the top trending
story on Facebook and Twitter
for four days running.
We had 939 million media
impressions by Thursday.
And it blew up in this viral
way that nobody ever expected.
And then I thought, well, it
can't get any bigger than that.
We really hit out of the park.
And then the Pope calls.
And the Pope wanted
us to-- right before.
He said, all of this attention
is going to be on Paris.
But we need to
keep the attention
on what's going on
for the environment
to get the leaders that
are there to pay attention.
And so he let us
use the Vatican.
This is St. Peter's Cathedral
as the backdrop for this--
do we have clips we can show?
Do we have anything cued up?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
we do have the UN.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: The UN.
OK, well, do you
want to look at that?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: But go
see "Racing Extinction."
You can get it on
iTunes, Amazon,
or you can order
it from Discovery.
I wish I had known it was going
to be this small of a group.
I could have just brought
them in my backpack.
You probably don't even know
what a DVD is anymore, do you?
But anyway, I'll get $1
from you if you actually
go buy the film.
But we're doing a
new indie right now
that will include the Vatican.
But anyway, did you want
to-- just wind up, I'm sorry.
You have a list of questions.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I've seen the
film several times already.
And it's incredibly
powerful and moving.
And the imagery is incredibly
evocative, as we've seen here.
I was really surprised by
some of the stats in the film.
Like you said, I didn't know
that much about a current mass
extinction event.
I was really
surprised particularly
by the 6 billion oysters
that died overnight
on the oyster farm, 70
million sharks that are killed
every year for shark fin soup.
Did you know about
these things as well?
Or were they
discoveries for you too?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: I didn't
know about acidification.
We're acidifying the
ocean to the point
where we're increasing it about
30% since the industrial era.
At the current rate
of acidification--
this is the burning of fossil
fuels-- about a third to half
of all the carbon
dioxide released
gets absorbed by the ocean.
That creates carbonic acid.
So anything with the carbon
structure-- plankton,
coral reefs, start to dissolve.
And that's what's
going on right.
At the current rates,
by 2050, all coral reefs
will be in a state of dissolved.
By 2100, they'll be gone.
I didn't know that.
That was horrific, because
trying to reverse acidification
is really tough, because
we're changing the chemistry
of the ocean at that level.
And you lose 25% of the
species in the ocean.
But there's a
billion people that
rely on coral reefs for
food, sustenance, recreation.
I was sitting in a room at
the Aspen Ideas Festival
with-- I was speaking there.
But I just took off
everything I could attend.
I found myself in a
room with Marvin Odum,
who is the head of Shell Oil and
half of his board of directors
and the heads of Duke Energy
and Southern Electric.
This is like, I don't know, in
my world, this is the devils.
And they were just like
this with a circular table.
We're all out having lunch.
And Marvin says, we have
scientists looking out
50 years.
And we're going to have
to double our oil and gas
production by then
to meet the demand.
I said, Marvin we have
scientists looking out
50 years, 500 years,
5 million years.
If you burn all
the gas you want,
we're not going to have
coral reefs for your children
to enjoy.
I said, how do you reconcile
your short-term business
interests for the long-term
economic, environmental damage
for a billion people
that rely on a food
source every generation?
He says, well, what
do you do for energy?
I said, I'm glad you asked.
I drive electric cars.
They're powered by solar panels.
My SUV-- is actually,
the license plate
on my electric car says, V, it
stands for vehicle, using sun.
It's the opposite of an SUV.
I power up my work and
my home by solar energy.
And he says, well, not
everybody can afford that.
These people started talking
among themselves again sort
of harrumphing.
But there was only
one woman in the room.
And afterwards, she had a copy
of "The Cove," because she
knows I'd be at this lunch.
And she said, would
you sign it for me?
I said, what's with your name?
And she goes-- it was Mrs. Odom.
It was Marvin's wife.
And I thought, OK,
this is how we're
going to get to the men
is through the women, who
have a lot more
innate compassion,
I think, for their kids.
And I knew I had to
make a movie that
was going to maybe
do an end around,
because you can sit there and
talk among your shareholders.
But one thing you can't ignore
is your kids and your wife.
It's just the way it is.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
I read an article
last year-- many
articles last year
actually saying that the melting
of the at the Antarctic ice cap
is now irreversible.
When you hear things like that,
it's kind of hard to keep hope.
So in the film,
"Racing Extinction,"
it does have a message of
hope with the Start One Thing
Campaign.
Would you like to talk
about that a little bit
before we take some questions?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: Yeah
First of all, the movie
is constructed so that if
you're in the audience,
you're thinking,
I'm just one person.
Everybody that we picked in
this film is a game changer.
They're doing stuff that's
absolutely remarkable.
We take an electric car.
We were going to build one.
We thought, well, why build
one when Elon Musk just
built the best one?
We go to visit him.
This is a time when
everybody thought
he was going go bankrupt.
He thought he was
going to go bankrupt.
We were going to
interview him in October.
And he wrote back
and said, Louie,
can we wait till the
end of this quarter?
If I don't hit my numbers,
I could go bankrupt.
Sure, Elon, do
whatever you want.
We photographed him three
months later, four months later,
the numbers were
slightly better.
The stock was at $34.
And now, it's at $250.
The new model that
he's came out with
had more orders, more preorders
than-- its the biggest product
sale in history in a single
day-- bigger than the iPhone.
So change happens
very, very quickly.
That's the cool thing.
It's what should
give us all hope.
When I was walking up to
the Tribeca Film Festival
to get this award, I
saw it was a picture
of 1905 of Broadway-- all
these horse drawn carriages
on Broadway.
If that same photographer
shot that same angle
seven years later, you
wouldn't have seen any horses.
It would have all been cars.
That's how fast life transforms.
Seven years is that
magic number that where
things start to ramp up.
Seven years ago,
we were punching--
there wasn't smartphones.
That's when the first smartphone
came out 7, 8 years ago.
We were punching the number
1 key to text six times
to get a capital C.
And now, I don't
have to tell you
what you can do with a
cell phone these days.
But it's like the Swiss
Army knife for our lives.
We do everything with it.
But that's seven years.
But if you're 25 years old,
that may seem like an eternity.
But for me, who turned nearly
60, that's not that long.
And so my hope is that
you can get this film out
there-- get some of
these disruptive ideas
like you don't need meat
for nutrition and protein.
In fact, in our film, we look
at the world's strongest guys
are vegan.
Nine time world champion arm
wrestler, Alexey Voevoda,
is a vegan.
The most accomplished ultra
runner male and female
in the world, Scott Jurek, just
ran the Appalachian Trail--
22 days-- double marathons a
day running the Appalachian
Trail-- 46 days.
And he does it on a vegan diet.
There's a reason.
Because it's cleaner.
It's better for your system.
It's healthier.
We interviewed doctors.
The head of the US
Heart Association.
And he is saying, no doctor
studies nutrition at all.
He said, we're inept to
deal with the diseases.
80% of the diseases that we
have are caused by what we eat.
And you could talk about
strokes-- heart conditions.
You can talk about
erectile dysfunction.
It's all related to basically
filling your body with animal
fats that clog up your system.
It's a plumbing
problem that we have.
And it has to do with
what we put in our mouth.
One of the doctors
told me he said,
I could fix all the
problems in America
right now, most of them, by
just wiring people's mouth shut.
There is a dissociative
relationship
between what we're
eating and what we
think it's doing to our body.
A vegan-- Sam Simon, the
co-founder of "The Simpsons"
told me that-- I don't
know if it's true or not.
But he said, a vegan driving
a Hummer uses less energy
than a meat eater on a bicycle.
So if you want to save the
world, change your diet.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
on racingextinction.com
I saw that there is an
Earth Day challenge.
Or you're calling on
people to participate.
And I've decided to
do something I've been
meaning to do for a long time.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: Which is?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Which is to
look into and start buying
carbon offsets for my travel.
What about you?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: We did the
same thing for the film.
The average person in
America burns about six,
6 to 7 tons of carbon.
That's a lot of carbon.
But you can offset it
with as little as $20
by setting aside acreage.
We do it in Ecuador.
We set aside acreage enough to
offset the whole entire travel
and production for the movie.
And it's not that it's
not that expensive.
You do some basic math.
When we did "The
Cove," the first film,
we didn't know about
carbon offsets.
Somebody spent three
months doing it,
because we didn't have
the tools back then.
And remember, it was
646 tons of carbon
we figured we used
to make that film.
So we offset it by
as much as we could
by putting the solar panels,
and getting electric cars,
and then setting
aside rain forests.
That's the easiest way to
do it, because rain forests
get knocked down
primarily for cows.
And what they're finding
if you leave it alone,
you can stitch back
these environments.
One of the big problems
with extinction
is you fracture the environment.
And populations can't
breed across that.
And you start to lose-- they
can't sustain themselves.
So what we're doing is helping
stitch back the rain forest.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So does anyone
have any questions or an Earth
Day challenge that they would
like to take up themselves?
We have a mic again.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: Is it on?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Is it on?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming here.
We hear a lot about
these things every day.
Like you mentioned, when it
comes to your kids and wife,
then we are more considerate
than-- it just occurred
to me that, oh, yeah, when
I go back to my house,
I think we are growing
things in the backyard.
And we think about, all
right, let's eat vegetarian.
Mostly, it's vegetarian cooking.
And let's bake organic stuff.
But when I am here,
just today in the lunch,
I picked whatever came first.
Like I didn't realize--
whatever chicken and fish
whether that came in
[INAUDIBLE] didn't quite.
I'm more in my commercial
mindset when I'm here.
And when I go back, I'm
more like long-term,
and what will happen
to my kids and family,
and that kind of mindset.
So I myself, I said, oh,
two personalities now.
So how can you now
coming to the-- I
like the hashtag
for the one thing.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS:
Start With One Thing.
AUDIENCE: Start With One Thing.
So I changed the laundry
to be crystal balls, which
are a kind of bioceramic.
They don't use detergents.
I was looking to a
bike in the summer.
Things one by one-- remove the
chemicals for the cleaning lady
to instead use Method or simple
stuff like vinegar and baking
soda.
But I don't see a
good way to convince.
I had a lot of trouble
convincing people hey,
it's OK if it
leaves a little bit
of dirty thing on the floor.
My cleaning lady
is not quite happy
because she thinks that
she's not doing a good job
with vinegar and baking soda.
Others are not happy
with washing the clothes.
So where is that I
can show them like,
hey, the incremental rewards.
When you set up a design doc
through a manager in our job,
for example, a software
engineer-- management
want to incremental returns.
They don't want to see, hey,
one year from now you'll
give something like that.
Can you make it more quarterly?
At least something keeps coming.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: Well,
at the end of our film,
it shows the result
of one action you do.
In New York, you're probably
not living in private homes.
But other parts of the
country where you're are
living in homes, you can
install solar panels.
It's the equivalent of taking
a gasoline car off of the road
and driving it halfway
around the Earth every year.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well, here, we
can actually choose our energy
source through Con Ed.
You can choose solar or wind.
It actually takes 30
seconds to sign up.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS:
Well, there you go.
And there's meatless
Monday campaigns.
Every American eats about
an average of 10,000 animals
in their lifetime.
So you think about--
you can look at it
from an ethical point of view.
You can look at it from
a health point of view,
or an environmental
point of view.
You can look at any
of those critically.
You can solve the
day whether you
decide to eat more
of plant-based diet
for any of those reasons, it can
be-- you can win that argument.
So I keep on coming back.
The simplest thing you
can do is change your diet
to more of a plant-based diet.
But, yeah, hopefully there's
a 1,000 different ways
that you guys will think of
besides the obvious ones of how
to say.
But support to look
at each action.
I look at every person in
this room as a super hero.
You have that potential.
You were probably
already doing it
at other points of your life.
When people say, what can I do?
I say, well, the
first thing I can say
is not you should do this.
It's who are you?
What do you do?
And try to use that
talent to amplify
the message to other people.
You look at freaking Google.
You can reach more people
with that little laptop
than a "New York Times"
writer can 10 years ago.
You could write a blog
to tell the cleaning
ladies of the world the
difference-- you could figure
out chemically how much better
it is for the environment
much better than
I probably could.
But I don't know who you are.
Everybody can do that and think,
OK, at am I really good at?
In my world, if you're a
filmmaker, make films about it.
If you're a writer,
write with your songs.
Michael Franti, the
singer for to Spearhead,
has been writing the
last couple days.
He's doing a song about
it for Earth Day today.
It depends on who you are
and what you're doing.
Everybody has massive amounts
of underused talent, I think.
AUDIENCE: Question here.
So one of the things you
said we can do individually
is to become vegetarians.
And one parallel I saw was we've
known for about 40 plus years
that cigarettes can kill us.
And we still have plenty of
people smoking cigarettes.
And that's such an individual--
if I keep doing this action.
I'm going to die.
And there is still
people doing it.
And I was wondering, do we
really have to rely on people
to break meat eating, which
has become so culturally
intertwined?
Do we need to rely on
people to individually make
that decision?
Or are there other
things we can do
to help affect that change
as opposed to waiting
50 years for people to
really stop eating meat?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: I'm
old enough that I
can remember that if
you came to an office
like this 30 years ago,
you could see people
smoking at their desk and
polluting the air-- 1997,
I think, or '98 were the
last commercial smoking
planes in America.
If you want to smoke
at Google, you probably
have to go outside
and around the corner.
I think there is going to be
a time in the very near future
where if you eat
meat, it's going
to be like you can do it
outside around the corner
with the smokers.
Because environmentally,
if you look
at the impact in
California where they-- I
forget what it was something
like 5,000 gallons of water
for a kilo of meat.
It's in the thousands
of gallons per pound
to raise meat when there's a
water such shortage going on.
It would be standing in
a shower for three days
so you can have your hamburger.
You know what I mean?
It's really out of
balance what we think of.
And a lot of the
crops are-- almonds,
1.1 gallons for to
raise an almond,
because they flood the fields.
It's very inefficient.
Somebody in this room
could probably figure out
now to do it more efficiently.
A lot of the
alfalfa that's grown
in California-- the alfalfa
is exported to China
where they feed cows.
Think of the energy loss there.
We're exporting our water
and our energy-- things
that we could-- plants
we could be eating,
not alfalfa, but other things
we could be using for ourselves.
It's just this is horrible
exchange of energy
that everybody should see it.
The environmentalists-- they see
it, and they're harping on it.
But, yeah, the Surgeon
General's smoking
was hazardous to your
health was 40 years ago.
But now, you need two things.
You need to change
public perception.
And you need to do
government legislation.
And I can't talk
about it right now.
But there's a really
big country, a huge one.
And it's not the
United States that's
going to announce next month
to reduce half the meat
consumption of a
very big country.
And that's going to be a mandate
that people have to follow.
They'll do it.
They will cut out subsidies.
So it's happening.
The leadership is coming
from other countries
other than America.
I have travelled around
the world quite a bit.
You guys probably do too.
We are looked at
as like-- you're
innovators-- you're
different than the rest
of the population of America.
But the rest of
America, we are not.
And we are looked at as
the fools of the world.
We are, because
we are the slowest
to get the carbon problem.
If you go to Europe and
Germany, 30% of their energy
is done with
alternative energy now.
Their exporting.
And people said, they have more
installed solar than we do.
And we have the same
solar for footprint here.
Seattle has the same solar
footprint as Germany.
And they're producing energy
so cheaply that they're
exporting it to Poland.
They're giving it away
at $0.01 a kilowatt.
So here we still hear
this diatribe-- solar
is too expensive.
No, it isn't.
That's a vestige of a campaign
by the fossil fuel companies
to say it's not practical.
The fossil fuel
companies also told us
that the divestment
campaigns weren't
going to work-- a couple
college kids getting Harvard
and Stanford to reduce
their fossil fuel
footprint in their
endowments wasn't going
to affect their bottom line.
Peabody Coal went bankrupt
last month-- the biggest coal
company in the world.
So it's happening.
We're bonding together.
But you need both.
You need legislation.
Warren Buffet, I used
to like that guy,
but I hate him now, because he
runs a company in Nevada that
just made it almost
impossible to get solar,
because he has a
fossil fuel company.
He made it almost impossible
for somebody in Nevada, which
is all sun and desert,
to put up solar panels
and get paid for it from the
state to sell back to energy.
And they're doing this.
This is their business model.
They know they can't do
it on a national level.
So they are going state
by state and trying
to make the right thing to do
very difficult for well-meaning
people.
So we need to
fight them and also
get legislation to
make it easy for people
to do the right thing.
And also, the impact of a
film is really powerful.
We just have anecdotal stuff.
But I was a judge at
Sundance this last year.
And a guy was coming
to the bathroom
rushing to get my seat.
And some guy says, I just saw
"Racing Extinction" last year.
It changed my life.
I said, how so?
He said, well, I had two
big cattle operations.
I just got rid of both of them.
And so films are a
really powerful tool.
Tell your friends
to see the film.
It's really important, because
you can sit there and talk
about to your cleaning
lady about the importance
of the environment that
it's really important what
you do around the house.
But you see a film like
"Racing Extinction"
or I don't know, "Chasing Ice,"
or any other environmental
films that are out
there, you don't
have to explain it anymore.
Buy them a copy.
Give it to them with their
bi-weekly check or whatever.
And one thing
about-- Ric O'Barry,
who was the hero
of the first movie.
He did "The Cove."
He was the guy that
captured and trained
the five female dolphins
that collectively
played the part of Flipper.
He told me that,
Louie, "The Cove"
was the best thing that
ever happened to him.
I said, why?
He said, because he
never asked explained
anybody what the problem is,
because you go to a dolphin
show.
And you see the dolphins
are smiling and laughing.
And the kids are having fun.
What's the problem?
The film shows you that the
dolphin has an eternal smile,
even when its head is
chopped off and sitting
on the slaughterhouse
floor and still smiling.
There have bigger brains.
And they are more sentient.
The neurons that are associated
with sentient neurons
are more familial.
They hang out in family pods
like orcas their entire life
with their mother.
When you start to see a film
like that, that explains what
the problem is,
it's like instead
of trying to explain it
and spend an hour or two
at a lecture, now he's got
tens of millions of people
around the country,
around the world, that
understand the problem.
And it's just a matter going
from country to country
to try to close these
businesses down.
Same thing with the film.
If you could get
the film out there--
Discovery did a great job of
it getting the film out there.
But we're still not
at that 10% level.
36 million people
worldwide is not that big.
We need to do that in America.
So tell your friends
about the film.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for being here.
And thanks for all
your great work.
I think it's very
sobering statistics
that you're sharing
in that I think
something like 50%
of greenhouse gases
are produced by
animal agriculture.
It's really terrible.
So I really appreciate your
call to action for people
to take up vegan
diets as one way
to combat this thing
that's going on.
My question is,
why do you think--
and I watch very closely
the COP21 and now
the US dietary guidelines, which
came out in 2015, both of which
seem to completely ignore the
issue of animal agriculture.
It wasn't even brought
up or mentioned.
Sustainability wasn't
even an afterthought
for the dietary guidelines.
So I'm wondering what
you think is the impetus
to have our politicians
and leaders talking
about these things openly?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS:
Yeah, whenever you
talk about dietary concerns,
you have the lobbyist
go in really hard-- the
lobbyist go to the politicians
to try to get the
language dumbed down.
I remember when the guidelines
came out five or six years ago
about, OK, eggs, dairy.
It's a real problem.
Milk should not be on
the food pyramid at all.
This got crucified.
It was too big of a
problem politically.
The information is still there.
The UN came out with the
guidelines for agriculture.
And it's called the long
shadow of agriculture.
And it said, we have to
reduce our consumption.
The 50%, if you
look at-- I think
it's 14.5% equivalent
of tailpipe emissions.
So the consuming of meat
in America for consumption
is more than that of all
the tailpipe emissions
of all the industries that burn
fossil fuels-- planes, trains,
automobiles.
That's for certain--
at least 14.5%.
50% is probably aggressive.
But the thing is
we know that this
is the one thing we can do right
away to turn the dials down.
But this is an area where
we have to do it internally.
We showed the film in Bogota,
Colombia several months ago.
And the day after--
this is a pretty heavy
meat-eating country-- the day
after the students got together
and met with the chancellor.
And he agreed to put
more of a vegan menu
with the several
thousand students there.
And this is the kind
of change we need.
We know that in
America, we don't work
on a national level as much.
I've testified against Sea
World for another film.
But what we're
doing statewide is
you could have a container
load of shark fins
that are legal to possess,
sell, or distribute
any way in Washington State.
But that container
is not open if you
go on to Oregon, or
Idaho, or somewhere else,
transport by truck
and get disseminated.
And US customs
officials say, there's
nothing we can do about it.
We just made it illegal to
import it into the docks.
And we're doing that in
California and in Oregon.
Texas is the first
southern state
that we have to
implement the law.
So we're working
with legislations,
but on a state-wide
basis like the same way
that Warren Buffet does it with
his minions-- those bastards.
And we're trying to
close them down so
we can take-- Seattle was the
third largest port in America.
And this is making it very,
very difficult to-- in fact,
it wasn't just shark fins.
There was ivory, rhino
horns, penguin-- 10 species.
So we can do it.
It doesn't take much to get
a referendum these days.
People talk about
these petitions.
And they get all the time.
People say, they don't work.
We killed SeaWorld
with petitions.
We got Willie Nelson,
Bare Naked Ladies--
these 10 musical acts out of 12,
to stop performing at SeaWorld.
Richard Bloom, who is a
representative from the state I
live in now, California,
came out with a law
that it was just a first salvo.
It was just an idea.
The law was that he was going
to stop the breeding of dolphins
in California.
That law, coupled
with my organization--
I run the Oceanic
Preservation Society-- there
were six people.
We bought copies
of "Blackfish"--
another film about
dolphins and orcas.
We bought copies of
"Blackfish" and "The Cove."
And we gave them to all
the shareholders of the 10
major investment of SeaWorld.
That coupled with Richard
Bloom's proposed law
caused the stock to
crash a billion dollars
in a single day.
And they haven't
recovered since.
It wasn't just our organization.
We worked with
other organizations.
That was a great
movie, "Blackfish."
But together, we can
do incredible things.
We're trying to get
it illegal to bring
animal parts, body
parts, for trophies
from Africa to America.
And UPS buckled with 167,000
members on the petition.
We're working right now
this week today with FedEx
to do the same thing.
We showed that we could
legally transport shark fins
to states using their system.
And we did it.
We photographed it.
There are people from
Federal Express complicit
with showing us how we could
avoid federal law by shipping
with them.
And so that is with their
head of marketing right now.
We will release it
probably today or tomorrow.
And if they don't buckle,
we'll go public with it
and start a petition.
So a 160,000
petitions is nothing
to get these companies
to change law.
All it takes is getting people
together-- getting people
to understand that taking the
15 seconds to 5 seconds it
takes to sign a petition
really helps-- sign and share.
AUDIENCE: So going back to
my question, who would you
petition and how to create 100
million vegans in the United
States tomorrow?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: I'm
working on a film--
the one I'm working with
James and Suzy Cameron.
We're working on that.
We're trying to get
Arnold Schwarzenegger
as an executive
producer as well.
Li Ka-shing, the
richest guy in Asia--
he's also an executive producer.
We'll get the film out there.
I work on that issue
every day with the idea
that it doesn't
happen overnight.
It's going to happen
with this film.
We want to get the
film distributed.
And then, at some point,
maybe release it for free.
The problem with people like
in the environmental movement.
They say, well, all your
care about is money.
You got to release it free.
It's really expensive to release
movies. "Racing Extinction" was
an $8 million, $9 million movie.
We sold it for $3 million.
I probably can't
tell those figures.
Just cut that from the record.
But it's an expensive
movie to give away.
I sold my house.
And I got $700,000
of my own money.
I'm not a rich guy.
Everything I own
is in that film.
And people say, why
don't you give it away?
It's like, you know what?
I've got to eat.
I've got insurance to pay.
If I run a Google
on the laptop, I've
got to pay for that laptop.
They're not giving
it away to me.
Life is expensive.
And I got crews that
need to get paid.
It's like you can't
give away art just
because it's well-intentioned.
And sometimes we have investors
that need to get paid.
But there is a scale.
We are very conscious that we
want to hit that 10% to 16.5%
number no matter how it happens.
We had a deal to sell
"The Cove" in China.
And somebody said,
oh, they are only
going to offer you $30,000.
Fine.
They are going to reach a half
a billion people in China.
We didn't do it.
And I can remember we went
to China about a year later.
And people that
were with my team
were signing autographs
on the street.
They recognize them
from the movie.
Somebody had pirated the movie
in Cantonese and Mandarin.
And it was like every school
kid of 15 to 25 years old
had seen "The Cove."
And now they are
celebrities on the streets.
But it's because it went viral,
because we didn't sell it.
Somebody has took it under the--
let's just-- I like this movie.
Let's just rip it.
And it went viral.
But for me, at some point,
I don't care about the money
so much.
I just want to get it out
there and solve the issue so we
can go on to something else.
There always has to be
another problem to solve.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Are there
any other questions?
All right, got one over there?
I think this will be
probably the last one.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thanks for being here.
You were on to covering China
for "Racing Extinction."
Could you tell us about maybe
the most horrifying moment
that you experienced there?
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: In China?
AUDIENCE: Right.
Or Hong Kong.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: Or Hong Kong.
Actually, we were in Guangzhou.
And they had the illegal
wildlife markets there.
And they had been
shutdown twice that year.
And it keeps on moving.
There's so much demand,
it keeps on springing up,
even though people face jail.
So you go there at like
3:00 in the morning,
and people are selling
just about everything
you can imagine-- a
lot of illegal wildlife
or a lot of wildlife that
we wouldn't eat in America.
But just the same--
just the screams
and the horrors of these
animals being put into cages
or being killed, because this--
blocks and blocks and blocks.
It would be like the
Meat District here--
like imagine every shop.
Like you go to the
Chelsea Market.
And there is 15
of them that size.
And they are all selling
endangered snakes,
endangered birds, all
kinds of farm animals,
but things that I
don't know dogs,
cats, rats-- they're
all being eaten.
And it was like
everything that had
a heartbeat, including
insects and larvae,
was being sold there.
And there was something
really disturbing about that.
It was done so openly.
And you know what?
In 1986, I was doing a
story for "Fortune Magazine"
on the biggest
independently owned
cattle ranches in America.
And I went to one that
was so big in Oklahoma
that they had their
own slaughter house.
And that convinced me to
become-- I wasn't a vegetarian.
I was a pescatarian.
But I stopped eating things
that walked right then
and haven't since.
When they kill
these animals, they
put a cap bolt to the skull.
It was supposed to
kill them instantly.
But it's an assembly line.
They did 500 a day-- 500 cows
a day in this small facility.
And they rip the skin off.
And they hang it upside down.
And it's supposed to be dead, as
people are shaving parts of it
off and putting it into
different bins and stuff.
And I remember this cow
was hanging upside down.
it was supposed to be dead.
And it was looking at
me and following me
as it went around in
this conveyor belt.
And it was still alive.
Part of it was still conscious.
And I thought at that point,
I don't want to be part of it.
Now, I made a conscious effort.
But when you see the scale that
was being done, it was amazing.
There was a rooftop in
Hong Kong that we went to.
And it was seven pallets
deep of shark fins.
And it was spread out all over
this roof overlooking Hong Kong
Harbor.
And you each shark
has seven fins to it.
And you see these
little baby ones.
I've dove all over the world.
And every time you
go back to a place,
you see less and less sharks.
And it was because of the
demand for shark fins.
Now, if you haven't seen
"The Cove," or sorry,
"Racing Extinction,"
what you realize
is that one of the
guys in our film
had photographed
a live shark fin.
What they do is a
lot of the sharks,
they just cut off the fins
and throw the shark back
to die, basically with all
its appendages cut off.
And the shark needs-- it
doesn't grow them back.
It needs to swim to breathe--
water rushing by its gills.
So these animals are left
to die on the bottom.
And one of the guys in
our movie had filmed this.
That film went viral
in China with a PSA
that Yao Ming, the
basketball player, did.
And the airing of
that film was seen
by more than a billion
people in Asia.
And that, along with
the legislation,
it's now illegal to serve shark
fin at banquets at government
banquets in China.
That one PSA helped reduce
the demand for shark fin soup
by 70%.
That's the power of imagery.
That's one of the themes running
through "Racing Extinction" is
that imagery is very powerful.
And that's why we do films.
That's why I was a photographer.
I was like, I did it to
try to change the world.
That's why I was
working-- the first story
I did for "National Geographic"
was a story on garbage
and recycling.
I started in 1981.
And people weren't talking
about recycling back then.
Now, there's recycling
in my hotel room.
But I was on the
vanguard of people.
But at "Geographic," when
we came out with that story,
we had 15 million people saw
the magazine at that point.
It was the second biggest
subscription magazine
in the world.
And it had a pass around rate
of about three to four people
would see each magazine.
So you could hit that
Malcolm Gladwell number--
that magic 15%-- just by virtue
of getting one article out
there that people see.
I am not saying that
50% of the population
became recyclers overnight.
But it became that first salvo.
The research shows
that if you want
to get a movie scene
in America, people
need to hear it six or seven
times before they'll actually
go see it.
So that means it has to
have a strong word of mouth.
The celebrity that's associated
with the movie on the cover
of a magazine that you adore.
You see bus stop
ads, and billboards,
and they blow it out
there-- $250 million movie--
will have $100 million
, $150 million.
If it's really a bomb, they
will throw another $50 million
to $100 million at
it, because they
know if they don't hit those
numbers the first weekend
or two before people figure
out that it's a piece of crap,
they won't see it.
As documentary filmmakers,
we don't have that.
But what we do is
we have good ideas.
We could light up the UN,
the Empire State Building,
or the Vatican.
I wish that was my idea.
But what we're
doing now is saying,
OK, the film is out there.
But we still work on cove
issues six years later.
Recently, SeaWorld just
because of all the pressure
we put on it, they announced
that they weren't going
to do captive breeding anymore.
They're stopping all
their orca programs.
And that's because of
"Blackfish," "The Cove."
The executive producer
of "Blackfish"
was inspired to become a
vegan by seeing "The Cove."
And she's never done a movie
before because of "The Cove,"
because she put the money
into "Blackfish." so there's
like a reciprocal effect of
doing one good thing that
can really go viral.
And I worked for
"National Geographic"
over the course
of about 18 years.
I did, I don't know,
13, 14 stories for them.
I can remember one time
watching somebody actually
see my movie-- my
story on a plane.
And he flipped through that.
It took me a year and
a half to do the story.
He flipped through
it as fast as you
could flip through a magazine.
It was heartbreaking.
But with a film,
you got 90 minutes
to change people's hearts.
And that's an extraordinary
amount of time these days.
You guys probably
know more than I do.
People say that people
don't more than a couple--
you can't have a YouTube
that's going to last
more than a couple minutes.
I don't know.
I think people have a propensity
to-- I binge watch "House
of Cards" when it comes out.
I'll do it one weekend.
I think if you have
a good story to tell,
people will endure
just about anything.
The trick that you have
with environmentalists
is how do you make a good story?
What we try to do is we
try to make a story that
is really entertaining.
"Rolling Stone" said
that, like I said,
"The Cove" was a cross
between the "Bourne Identity"
and "Flipper." "Racing
Extinction" is really
the result of me watching too
many Jacques Cousteau specials
and James Bond movies as a kid.
We have a Tesla
that we tricked out.
We wanted to make this Bond car.
So we have a
luminescent paint job.
We use it for getaways.
We have a disappearing
license plate.
We have a
forward-looking infrared
that comes out of
the front on a Gimbal
so we can see carbon
dioxide in real time.
We have a 16,000-lumen projector
that comes out of the back with
a hatch on a robotic arm so we
can project it on skyscrapers
in real time.
The car is freaking amazing.
But we knew that we had to
have some sort of hook in there
so that if a kid of a
certain age saw the film,
they would say you got to
at least go see the car.
They may not understand--
they will get the exposition.
They will get the story on
the way to seeing the car.
But there all sorts of
interesting characters
in this film that hopefully
hook people into the film.
There's a lot going on in this
one little 90-minute sequence.
But 90 minutes is
that enough time
to actually change the DNA.
Somebody should do
some research on it.
But I think that we used to
read books and get changed.
We're not reading
books en masse anymore.
But we're watching films.
And we're watching episodic
television by the buckets full.
But if you can make a film
that changes people's hearts,
we can change their behavior.
I know that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All right,
well, thank you very much.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS:
Thank you, everybody.
Appreciate it.
Sure.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: And yeah,
Be sure to check out
the hit "Racing Extinction."
It's available online.
And check out the website
racingextinction.com
for local viewings.
LOUIE PSIHOYOS: Great.
Thank you all.
Cheers.